nothing oh no not this
[Music]
hi i'm mae and this is my girlfriend hey
i'm india and this is also my girlfriend
hi i'm derek lewis hi i'm cedric dodd
and we met in college and we became best
friends and we've been living together
basically ever since yeah yeah hi my
name is tucker and i'm here with my
friend
roommate jacob friends first roommate
second exactly
are you guys excited about writing these
products i'm very excited to review
these pride products because
i've been seeing a lot of kind of cringy
[ __ ] around here
so maybe we'll get some good stuff a
little bit nervous for what we're gonna
see
and not me i'm diving in head first
if you like it you'll put the yes up
and if you don't then you switch it
around and pass
great starting it's simple
is it kombucha can we touch it oh
and it's cute i like it i will say i
really like this brand
have you had kombucha before i have
never had kombucha no
never girl i don't love kombucha because
i feel like kombucha kombucha kombucha
kombucha the gays love health so this is
organic dr kombucha love wins
we love that is that the flavor laven
yeah flavor
love wins it's not too obnoxious it's
not at all does it
donate to anything trevor project the
lady i like that we're supporting the
trevor project that like means a lot
i'm down like i would drink it do you
want to try it can we
oh do we get to rate the cups wait
writing this product too
absolutely obsessed okay pride comes
okay let's see cheers
i like it don't love it really
i kind of hate it but i like the concept
and that's like
not on them that i don't like the flavor
yeah i think i said yes
i'm gonna still have to pass i'm sorry
i'm a fan
and also given back i mean this is gonna
be a yas for me
i'll give it a soft yes wow okay he
absolutely hates the driver
but i actually love the time i really
like it
i give it a yes but i don't like the
flavor
oh wow okay so this is famously a fan as
they say in the biz
oh you go first i don't know i don't
think i can you know
like oh
yeah hit me does it make you feel proud
no and i think that it has great wind
speech what are these in church when i
need these in church give me a hot
could you imagine you're all bam amen
praise the lord
one trip to weho it's broke oh fully
oh my god i'm so sorry
i would just like to talk to everyone in
the lgbt community right now i'm so
sorry that i broke your product
she doesn't seem very durable um okay
well durability we're looking at a hard
naw
i think that could have been user's
fault
can't say i'm a fan i said a joke what
was the joke on him
i'm not a fan oh
thanks i'm gonna have to say oh yeah i
say yes too
i'm going to give it a yes yes for me
pass
okay is this for loops but
with tony the tiger known gay icon
tony the tiger do we think one of them
is queer of course
these are like the kellogg universe
which is like
only second to the marvel universe oh
very support glass you upload the qr
code
and then they donate three dollars to
glads anti-bullying i like it that's
like so great
oh yes i think it's good uh-huh that's
pride in a nutshell
sugar i just thought too he him she
heard they them
add your own oh oh that's really oh
that's so cute
yes my favorite so far yeah
i mean same yes
i ate all my cereal by the way
oh pride pack skittles and they're
all gray and they're all grey is that a
joke like is this a joke or no
only one rainbow manners ring pride so
they took away their
rainbow yeah so we can shine so we can
be bright and stuff
come on i love that
i'm still like not i'm not like sold on
the meaning it's a bit confusing
are there actually no colors on the
inside there's no way wait so it's just
a bunch of gray skittles
oh my god oh wow
i don't know about it oh it's really
jarring if i'm looking at it it kind of
just looks like i'm
eating like ash you know you got
what's a good one i don't know red yeah
yeah i got red i don't see this and go
oh that's a pride product
this tells me no gay people work at
skittles that's a smart way for them to
make sure that they're in
doing like the inclusion of the rainbow
because their whole thing is about the
rainbow so then for them to flip it
that is such a creative way to flip yeah
the best way for them
they should get a raise i like it oh
can i mean the middle i don't know no i
like it's like a quiet
yes like
i mean maintained the original flavor
branding
it's a yes for me me too
see now we're talking this is a product
that guys said
what's the point there's none just say
you want to make money on us
and go they've raised over 1 million
dollars for its non-profit partners
wow read the fine print wow i dare you
to say a bad thing about listerine now
they're perfect they're beautiful they
look like linvangelista
so if i removed the whole thing even the
rainbow would be taken away
oh my gosh so picture this it's a
homophobe going through the store where
disposable
rips it off stupid you know the strips
that you take out yeah red orange
elegant horrible red orange yellow green
blue purple
are you kidding me i agree listerine
hire me i'm gonna have to pass
yeah i love the serene but pass
i'm still giving it a gas i wanna sleep
too
okay pride backpack kind of cute i mean
i love a small backpack
wait i think it's honestly kind of it's
it's not so overwhelming it's not so
aggressive in your face
we're working with a lot of stuff here
to me it's like this was put together
last minute by the company
going to a pride parade having this
little guy yeah
she could last through pride a pride
event yeah
like the stitching here and like like
the quality like that's the community
yeah the idea is there i also like that
they have like the updated pride flag
like with the brown
as well like if you saw me walking down
the street what would you think would
you be like oh my god i love your bag
i'm like oh the rainbow now that's about
it i see that what do you give the
backpack
the backpack is the ass from me agreed i
give it it
yes oh my god who's that who is she
i love how gay me too
i think that there's nothing actually
gay about it
everything is pride the only thing
that's not is the barefoot itself
it's still going to taste like it's just
going to still be barefoot
i think that it's great i think that
they did a good job in terms of like
directing your eye
yeah toward towards the thing towards
the label
and is also embracing this month do we
need to try like a full
like bottle oh okay well you weren't
supposed to open it
i got excited blast people got a little
excited i think it's cute i would have
preferred like um
a vodka proud ally of the lgbtq plus
community since 1988
and that's interesting to me because
what before 1988 were they not an ally
barefoot probably started then okay this
one gets a
hearty ass from me i agree sorry girlie
sorry yes me too if you were throwing
like a pride brunch yeah
that's the one that you want to get yep
[Music]
okay oh
my god nothing oh no
not this we have a live performance are
you
kidding me it's a choice i'm gonna say i
would never
wear this out i mean easy i mean he's
working the crowd yeah i've never been
more yes about anything in my life no
agreed
see the thing is is that you pull it off
really really well i could never
can we know the price 49.99
it's pricey i was thinking kind of a
steal
so now where would you wear this where
would it be
thank you good answer can you model it
some more for us yeah
yeah in three and four what are your
notes
what are my notes i would honestly wear
that it's awful
i don't have an ounce of fashion in my
bones
stop it can i really it will clash
perfectly with your floral shirt
what's the material it feels like a
costume yeah
it's giving me umbrella material so what
do you think
you're awfully silent now things have
changed
wow oh not this pocket it's just a flap
i would give it a yes
i'll give it a yes either way even on me
yeah
sure that's my roommate
i'm gonna give it a yes on you any ass
on me because you have to love yourself
keep the tag on return what do you think
overall with these products overall
disappointed
you changing a label for the month of
june
that's the least that you can do to show
your allyship and to show that you
want to support clearly i'm an easy like
what am i the exact demographic they
were going seriously
honestly kind of pleasantly surprised i
do think it's a little bit of baiting
i like that these companies are trying
i think the moral of the story is go
into it with really low expectations
because most brands don't actually know
what game we want
right
[Music]
you